[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem Mittwoch Norbert Lehmann ist auch
wieder dabei für den Sport
landesweite Proteste im Iran nach dem
Ende der 40-tägigen Trauerzeit um die
junge masseamini gehen tausende gegen
das islamische Herrschaftssystem auf die
Straße
die Erderwärmung schreitet voran die UNO
sieht zwar Fortschritte im Kampf gegen
den Klimawandel doch reichten die
Bemühungen bei weitem nicht
und Pläne zur Cannabis Legalisierung
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach will das
erwerb- und Besitz von bis zu 30 Gramm
straffrei bleiben
[Musik]
sie lassen sich nicht einschüchtern seit
Wochen protestieren Iranerinnen und
Iraner gegen die Führung ihres Landes
heute erst recht denn vor genau 40 Tagen
starb Marsa armini in Polizeigewahrsam
nachdem die junge Frau von
Sittenwächtern festgenommen worden war
weil ihr Kopftuch nicht korrekt saß im
ganzen Land wagten sich Menschen auf die
Straße auch am Grab von Marsa armini in
ihrer Heimatstadt im Norden Irans Jörg
Brase berichtet
Studenten der Medizinischen Fakultät in
Isfahan rufen nach Freiheit ähnliche
Bilder in ach was in Mascha
ihr seid Verbrecher schreien sie den
Sicherheitskräften entgegen die auf
einer Brücke in teheranstellung bezogen
haben im Internet kursieren heute viele
solche Videos am 40 Tag nach Masa
arminis Tod ließ ihre Familie erklären
dass man keine Trauerfeier abhalten
werde um Schwierigkeiten zu vermeiden
dies geschah vermutlich unter dem Druck
der Behörden trotzdem marschiert eine
Menschenmenge in aminis Heimatstadt
sakes Richtung Friedhof an einigen
Stellen im Land kommt es zur
Auseinandersetzungen mit den
Sicherheitskräften das Regime reagiert
weiter mit Peitsche und mit Zuckerbrot
gestern an der hagenazier-universität in
der Heiligenstadt kommt
Regierungssprecher Ali bahadori jaromi
spricht zu Studenten sucht den Dialog
wie er sagt doch er wird niedergebrüllt
wir wollen nicht mit Mördern reden rufen
einige und immer wieder Frauen Leben
Freiheit ja auch er unterstütze diese
Ziele sagt Regierungssprecher tachomi
aber er habe das Gefühl dass er hier
nicht erwünscht sei erhoffe man könne
irgendwann in einer besseren Atmosphäre
reden aber ihr schreit ja nur sagt es
und geht
sie können nicht miteinander reden und
die Demonstranten wollen es auch nicht
für sie gibt es nichts mehr zu
besprechen
[Applaus]
ernüchternd ist das Ergebnis eines
un-berichts kurz vor der
Weltklimakonferenz danach nehmen die
Bemühungen zwar zu aber es reicht nicht
schon jetzt liegt der weltweite
Temperaturanstieg bei 1,1 Grad und die
Folgen sind längst spürbar der Hitze
Sommer hierzulande mit Temperaturen über
40 Grad im Mittelmeerraum verheerende
Waldbrände und den Pakistan steht ein
Drittel des Landes unter Wasser selbst
wenn alle bisherigen Zusagen umgesetzt
würden steigt die globale Temperatur
nach UN-Schätzungen um 2,5 Grad bis Ende
des Jahrhunderts trotz aller Projekte
Marc Hugo
sogar hier tut sich was die Mega City
Dubai ist mit ölreich geworden jetzt
entsteht in dem Emirat der größte
Solarpark der Welt
klimaambitionen nehmen weltweit zu wenn
auch noch zu wenig das zeigt der neue
UNO-Bericht werden alle aktuell
vorliegenden klimapläne so auch
umgesetzt könnte der Treibhausgasausstoß
im besten Fall zwar sinken die
Erderwärmung würde trotzdem um 2,5 Grad
steigen im Vergleich zu 19 Jahrhundert
nach dem Pariser Abkommen dürfen wir es
allerdings maximal zwei möglichst 1,5
Grad sein dafür sind die Anstrengungen
zu niedrig es passiert Klimaschutz
weltweit ja aber viel viel zu langsam
wir sind immer noch in einer Situation
dass die Regierung dieser Welt den
Klimawandel nicht als Krise betrachten
es ist eine Krise wir sind existenziell
bedroht auch die deutschen Pläne reichen
noch nicht so die Klimaforscher mit dem
habe es 2045 klimaneutral zu werden sei
man aber auf einem guten Weg Deutschland
hat sehr ambitionierte Ziele und steht
von den Zielen international gut da in
der Umsetzung hapert es wenn man etwa
den Verkehrssektor denkt und auch daran
dass wir jetzt vorübergehend vermehrt
Kohle nutzen müssen das muss natürlich
jetzt korrigiert werden in zehn Tagen
beginnt in Ägypten die
Weltklimakonferenz wie geht besserer
Klimaschutz mitten in der Energiekrise
das wird wohl eines der Themen dort sein
das deutsch-französische Verhältnis ist
angespannt bei einem arbeitsmittagessen
wollten Kanzler Scholz und Präsident
macron heute die Wogen glätten für Ärger
sorgt vor allem die Energiepolitik des
Bundeskanzlers weil der zu Hause 200
Milliarden Euro zur Bewältigung hoher
Energiekosten bereitstellt aber gegen
einen europäischen gaspreisdeckel ist
und stimmigkeiten gab es zuletzt auch in
Verteidigungsfragen ein schwieriger
Termin also auch wenn die Begrüßung
routiniert freundlich war
normalerweise gibt es immer
Pressekonferenzen nach solchen Treffen
diesmal nicht eine Arendt in Paris wie
belastet ist das deutsch-französische
Verhältnis
naja es lief schon mal besser zwischen
den beiden Ländern und dass ich Immanuel
macron und Olaf Scholz nicht zu einem
gemeinsamen Statement vor den Kameras
durchringen konnten das hat schon alle
irritiert zu lang ist offenbar die Liste
der Unstimmigkeiten die hier nicht
komplett abgearbeitet werden konnte um
zu verstehen wie es um das
deutsch-französische paar steht ist es
wichtig zu wissen was eigentlich heute
geplant war nämlich ein Treffen
sämtlicher Minister bei der Regierungen
in einem durchaus feierlichen Rahmen der
traditionelle deutsch-französische
Ministerrat kurzfristig abgesagt
stattdessen nun ein Arbeitsessen zu
zweit ein Tetra Ted um die Beziehung zu
kitten immerhin haben die beiden sich
mit drei Stunden relativ viel Zeit dafür
genommen
Dankeschön für diese Einschätzung aus
Paris an der Arendt war das
lange hat die Bundesregierung über die
Beteiligung Chinas am Hamburger Hafen
gestritten trotz massiver Bedenken
mehrere Ministerien hat das Kabinett
jetzt entschieden Einstieg ja aber mit
Einschränkungen heißt konkret der
chinesische Staatskonzern cosco darf
maximal
24,9% des Container Terminals toller Ort
übernehmen ursprünglich geplant waren 35
Prozent damit soll der Einfluss des
Unternehmens begrenzt werden so hat
cosco etwa kein Vetorecht bei
geschäftlichen Entscheidungen
der Bundeskanzler wollte unbedingt
diesen Deal mit China und hat sich
durchgesetzt gegen den Willen von sechs
Ministerien
in Berlin zu welchem Preis ja der Preis
ist die Stimmung in der Koalition das
muss man wohl sagen denn die war zwar
vorher auch schon nicht rosig aber jetzt
ist sie schwer angeschlagen Grüne und
FDP haben dem Kompromiss zwar zugestimmt
aber nur mit sehr lautem Zähneknirschen
aus beiden Parteien hört man hier heute
dass diese Entscheidung falsch sei und
das Auswärtige Amt hat extra im
Protokoll vermerken lassen dass der
Beschluss der die ich den chinesischen
Einfluss auf deutsche und europäische
Infrastruktur
unverhältnismäßig erweitere und es
Auswärtige Amt spricht auch von
erheblichen Risiken dem hat sich die FDP
angeschlossen man fragt sich so ein
bisschen warum macht Olaf Scholz das
denn der Unmut über seinen Stil und die
Kommunikation des Kanzleramtes hatte
sich schon aufgebaut rund um die
akw-entscheidung jetzt fragen sich viele
bei Grünen und FDP erneut warum wird da
so kommuniziert warum gibt es dann
kurzfristig Machtworte und dabei stehen
ja die großen Probleme die die Koalition
noch vor sich hat wie zum Beispiel
Fragen des Klimaschutzes oder auch die
Frage wie geht man nächste nächstes Jahr
mit der Schuldenbremse um noch überhaupt
noch bevor also da ist die Frage wie
kann man da gemeinsam zu einem Stil
zurückkommen dem man sich einmal
gegenseitig versprochen hat nämlich
Gemeinsamkeit und Augenhöhe Dankeschön
nach Berlin charcotala bernergie
bei einem anderen Thema ist sich die
Ampel weitgehend einig sie will kleine
Mengen von Cannabis legalisieren
ausschließlich für Erwachsene die ersten
Pläne dazu hat das Kabinett heute
verabschiedet sie sind nicht nur bei
Ärzten umstritten kritiker fürchten eine
Verharmlosung der Droge Ines Trumps
berichtet
Cannabis immer mehr Jugendliche und auch
Erwachsene konsumieren es Tendenz
steigend das bisherige Verbot habe
nichts gebracht so Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach für ihn Zeit was Neues zu
versuchen die Legalisierung von Cannabis
nicht den Cannabiskonsum ausdehnen
sondern wir wollen einen besseren Kinder
und Jugendschutz und einen besseren
Gesundheitsschutz erreichen all die
regulierenden Aspekte dienen diesem
Zweck die Eckpunkte die das Kabinett
heute abgesegnet hat Erwerb und Besitz
von 20 bis 30 Gramm zum Eigenkonsum
sollen straffrei sein privater
Eigenanbau wird in begrenztem Umfang
erlaubt und der Verkauf soll in
lizenzierten Fachgeschäften möglich sein
Zutritt ab 18 Jahren eine
Entkriminalisierung ist das Ziel
staatlich kontrollierte Lieferketten
statt Schwarzmarkt der also Vertrieb und
der Anbau sollen staatlich kontrolliert
werden das bedeutet wir streben anders
also der die gesamte Menge die hier
vertrieben und auch konsumiert wird dass
sie in Deutschland produziert werden
soll Ärzte kritisieren dieser Vorschlag
erleichtere den Zugang für Jugendliche
zu Cannabis statt ihn zu erschweren
dabei ist ihr Hirn besonders gefährdet
sie früher man mit dem Konsum beginnt
desto schädlicher ist dass wir das
Gehirn und das kannst du schweren
gehirnstörungen kommen im psychosen-
um die Eckpunkte liegen nun vor einen
Gesetzentwurf soll es aber erst geben
wenn die EU-Kommission grünes Licht gibt
für die Cannabis Legalisierung in
Deutschland
wir schauen nach Karlsruhe dort hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht das
informationsrechts der
Bundestagsabgeordneten gestärkt und
entschieden dass die Bundesregierung das
Parlament auch in Fragen europäischer
Sicherheitspolitik informieren muss
frühzeitig und umfassend geklagt hatten
Grüne und Linke unter anderem weil sie
2015 nicht frühzeitig genug über die
eu-militäroperation Sofia gegen
Schlepper im Mittelmeer informiert
worden waren
die Sportvereine schlagen Alarm wegen
der galoppierenden Energiepreise können
viele ihre Anlagen nicht mehr
unterhalten die Sportminister der Länder
stehen auf ihrer Seite und fordern
Unterstützung vom Bund die Vereine
müssten so lange wie möglich
weitermachen können Sport sei
unverzichtbar für den Zusammenhalt der
Gesellschaft und das sei im Moment
wichtiger denn je Carsten Behrendt hat
mehr
die moderne Heizungsanlage für die
Tennishalle ist der Stolz der Füchse
Berlin sie heizt nur wenn die Plätze
drinnen vermietet sind lange haben sie
diskutiert ob sie die Traglufthalle
diesen Winter aufbauen denn auch der
Tonraum die Duschen und die
Geschäftsstelle benötigen teure Energie
wir rechnen mit 60 bis 80.000 Euro
Mehrkosten im kommenden Jahr das ist
dramatisch das ist dramatisch das trifft
uns als Verein auch wenn wir groß sind
wirklich stark laut einer aktuellen
Umfrage sehen 5,6% der deutschen
Sportvereine die Energiekrise als akute
Existenzbedrohung starke Auswirkungen
fürchten 41,8% leichte Auswirkungen 42,7
und keine Auswirkungen
9,8%. wir haben 87.000 Vereine in
Deutschland die Leisten ein wertvollen
Beitrag für den Zusammenhalt in unserer
Gesellschaft und das alles ist durch die
Verteuerung durch die Energiekrise bei
den Vereinen gefährdet sorgen auch bei
den caroa Dachsen auch wenn Sie wie die
meisten Vereine keine eigene Sport
besitzen die Dachse nutzen
Schulsporthallen zum Pauschalpreis
Strom- und Heizung zahlt das Land Berlin
sie hoffen dass das so bleibt
[Musik]
auf alle Fälle durften die Preise nicht
auf die Vereine umgelegt werden was ich
hoffentlich auch in der Zukunft nicht
passieren wird und damit wir auch
weiterhin so preisgünstig Sport anbieten
können weil wir können nicht eins zu
eins die Mehrkosten auf unsere
Mitglieder abwälzen das geht nicht die
Bundesregierung hat angekündigt dass der
Sport vom energie-rettungsschirm
profitieren soll wie und wann ist noch
offen
Tierwohl das ist ein Begriff mit dem der
Lebensmittelhandel gern wird heißt
bessere Stelle mehr Auslauf weniger
Gedränge es kommt aber auch darauf an
welche Tiere überhaupt gehalten werden
Masthühner etwa werden Tom zum Teil so
gezüchtet dass sie sich vor lauter
Muskelfleisch kaum noch bewegen können
der Discounter Lidl ist jetzt mit dem
Vorwurf konfrontiert sowas zuzulassen
farblos silalahi berichtet
ein geflügelmastbetrieb in Niedersachsen
Zulieferer unter anderem für den
Discounter Lidl diese Bilder haben
Tierschützer heimlich aufgenommen
tausende Hühner auf engstem Raum
zusammengepfercht Tiere wie sie in der
Natur nicht vorkommen würden womöglich
viel hühnerbrustfleisch abzuwerfen so
überzüchtet dass sie sich kaum noch auf
den Beinen halten können das Trinkwasser
nicht erreichen und qualvoll verdursten
kein
einzelfallsbetrieb befinden worden wäre
dann würden wir ungefähr dieselben
Bilder sehen weil nämlich das absolute
Problem das Standardproblem in der
Wiener Mast die Qualzucht ist Lidl
kündigt in einer schriftlichen
Stellungnahme gegenüber dem ZDF an die
Vorfälle prüfen zu wollen
Lidl spricht sich in aller Deutlichkeit
gegen Tierquälerei aus wir nehmen
jegliche Vorwürfe sehr ernst wir haben
umgehend um eine Stellungnahme gebeten
und eine unabhängige Prüfung durch
externe Sachverständige veranlasst das
Fleisch aus dem Betroffenen Mastbetrieb
wird unter anderem für Lidls Eigenmarke
Metzger frisch verwendet in seinem
Werbeprospekt bietet der Discounter 600
Gramm Hühnerbrust für 4,49€ an Kilopreis
7,48 Euro zum Vergleich
bio-hähnchenbrust kostet im Supermarkt
das Fünffache Tierwohl hat eben auch
seinen Preis
jetzt wird es innovativ es geht um neue
Technologien die unsere Gesellschaft und
den Standort Deutschland voranbringen
sollen für solche Innovationen gibt es
den Deutschen Zukunftspreis dotiert mit
250.000 Euro vor wenigen Minuten hat
Ihnen der Bundespräsident verliehen an
ein Team das ein neues Mikroskop
entwickelt hat Andreas Linke
vor wenigen Minuten überreichte
Bundespräsident Frank-Walter Steinmeier
den Zukunftspreis an die drei Forscher
von Carl Zeiss aus Jena
2014 gab es bereits eine Nobelpreis für
die Entwicklung eines Mikroskops das bis
in einzelne Zellen schauen kann das
jetzt preisgekrönte deutsche Projekt ist
noch mal ein weiterer Schritt in diesem
Verfahren das Problem der Forscher
Mikroskope leuchten auf die Zellen aber
dieses Licht beeinflusst die einzelnen
Zellen wenn es sie nicht sogar schädigt
wir haben den Bedarf gesehen
dass dieses Problem der fotoschädigung
für die Zellbiologie gelöst werden muss
und zu dem Zeitpunkt gab es noch keine
Idee wie diese Lösung eigentlich
aussehen kann die Lösung heute ganz
dünne lichtschichten sogenannte
leitsheets die nur den Bereich erhellen
in denen das Objektiv schaut die
einzelnen Schichtbilder fügt die
Software zusammen Lampe und objektiv
stehen dabei im Winkel zueinander was
allerdings neue optische Probleme
erzeugt aber auch diese gleich das
Mikroskop aus
Aufnahmen die die Teilung menschliche
Zellen zeigen mit dem neuen Mikroskop
können Forscher auf kleinster Ebene live
im Leben beim Leben zuschauen
viertel nach zehn können Sie das die
Verleihung des zukunftspreises hier im
ZDF sehen und jetzt bist du dran mit
Champions League ja mit zwei
erfolgreichen deutschen Vereinen gestern
Abend starke Leistungen von Leipzig
gegen Titelverteidiger Madrid ein
verdienter 3:2 Heimsieg die erste
Niederlage übrigens für Real nach 16
Pflichtspielen Leipzig mit guten Chancen
aufs Achtelfinale in der Sieges Euphorie
werden auch nach hartem Kampf nochmals
zusätzliche Kräfte freigesetzt ich freue
mich für die Jungs dass sie sich belohnt
haben dass sie an sich geglaubt haben
45.228 Zuschauer sehen von der ersten
Minute an mutige Leipziger die Belohnung
folgt in der 13 quadiol der
Innenverteidiger mit Köpfchen das 1:0 in
der 18 Minute Raum von einem kunku 2:0
für Leipzig kurz vor dem Seitenwechsel
real mit dem Anschlusstreffer zum 2:1
und kurz vor dem Ende der zweiten
Halbzeit im Blickpunkt Timo Werner das
3:1 in der Nachspielzeit diese unnötige
Aktion von und kunku Rodrigo zum 3:2
entstand die Ko-Runde zum Greifen nah
Dortmunder gegen hat vorzeitig das
Achtelfinale erreicht nach dem 0:0 zu
Hause gegen ManCity der Held des Abends
bvb-torwart Gregor Kobel der hält in der
58 minute den Elfer des zuvor von Emre
Chan gefolgten Manchester Stürmers Riad
marez bravoös ja und sichert so
Punktgewinn und Einzug in die Ko-Runde
und heute Abend spielen Frankfurt
Leverkusen und die Bayern die sind ja
schon fürs Achtelfinale qualifiziert der
Gegner Barcelona aber der steht mit dem
Rücken zur Wand selbst ein Sieg könnte
dem Team von Robert Lewandowski nicht
reichen fürs weiterkommen
die Zuspitzung auf Bayerns Treffen mit
Robert Lewandowski nimmt inzwischen
muntere Formen an jedenfalls bei Thomas
Müller auf der Anreise nach Barcelona
wir kommen
runter
der Pole hatte vor der Saison seinen
Wechsel von Bayern nach Spanien
Betrieben jetzt droht ihm das Aus in der
Champions League
wir haben noch eine kleine Hoffnung ist
aber schwer wenn du es nicht in der Hand
hast du zweifelst dann noch mehr
zu dem frühen Spiel kann Mailand gegen
Pilsen am Abend Lewandowskis Champions
League aus besiegeln egal die Barcelona
spielt gewinnen die Bayern stehen Sie
als Gruppen erster fest
ja alle Höhepunkte alle Spiele zu sehen
bei uns Champions League Sportstudio
Champions League so heißt es knapp 23
Uhr und schon jetzt gibt es die
Lottozahlen sie lauten 16 21 23 24 32 56
und die Superzahl 1 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 557
ungewöhnlich warme Tage sind weiterhin
das große Thema bei den Meteorologen
mehr dazu gleich von östentelli im
heute-journal um viertel vor zehn
begrüßt Sie Anne Gellinek und wir sind
morgen wieder da machen Sie sich einen
schönen Abend auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter eine Serie von
ungewöhnlich warmen Tagen steht uns nun
bevor das liegt daran dass dieses Hoch
hier festgetackert über Mitteleuropa
hängt und das Tief auf dem Atlantik
ebenfalls dazwischen diese warmluftdüse
von Spanien Frankreich bis nach
Deutschland wird bis Sonntag immer
wieder warme Luft herangeführt und so
sind bis zu 27 Grad möglich in der Nacht
bildet sich in der Mitte und im Süden
Nebel auch in der norddeutschen
Tiefebene insgesamt bleibt es trocken
bei tiefsten Temperaturen von 12 Grad
ganz im Westen und vier Grad am
Alpenrand und morgen nach Auflösung von
Nebelfeldern dann viel Sonnenschein hier
Richtung Main kann es durchaus auch mal
länger dicht bleiben und auch im Norden
aber das zeigt sich auch mal die Sonne
die Temperaturen dazu höchste Werte bis
24 Grad im Südwesten 22 Grad am
Niederrhein und in der Mitte um
10 Grad die nächsten Tage die
Temperaturen gehen noch weiter hoch
Freitag bis 27 Grad sehr ungewöhnlich
hohe Temperaturen Samstag 26 Sonntag bis
24 Grad und immer viel Sonnenschein ein
schönen Abend